do you think
that solomon was doomed to go down this
particular path
no matter what or was there any chance
at all he could have lived
happily ever after if his wife and child
had survived
the films talk about lineage and how we
bring the past forward
solomon absolutely is the originator of
this crime
in this town and um and
would he have done it if life didn't go
that way it's almost
a moot i think he would have because i
think
the the issue with solomon is
with all of us is that we all get we all
find out who we are when
when we're in trouble when when bad
things happen
and and solomon is uh
he he chose weakness he he chose the
easy way out he chose
to uh oppress people for his own benefit
and i i i don't
think his wife and child
needed to to die for that to happen he
would have
he would have always blamed something
for his loss
or for his lot in life and for his
shortcomings
here's a specific scene in 1666 i really
wanted to ask you about it's when
solomon first gets into the meeting
house and he realizes what the pastor
has done do you think he is just walking
down
the aisle there just basically saying
you know this is the results this is
what i did and i'm okay with it or is
there any regret on his end at all
it's a lee janiak film which means that
like
every everybody's a human being
he made it he made the deal he made but
then now he has to live with the
consequences and
he that is absolutely regret
guilt has to be mixed in there does that
then change his behavior
and we see that it doesn't it it doesn't
stop him from
keeping the lie going now this one does
get into
1978 a little bit but i was wondering
what kind of conversations did you have
with lee
about what draws solomon and nick
to sarah and ziggy specifically is there
a
a constant quality between the two of
them that
drives him to protect them even while
this whole plan is unfolding around them
it's it's a wow that's a good question
i think we absolutely did talk about it
i think
uh i i think
they're both probably all the goods are
drawn
to um are drawn to
originality and are drawn to greatness
and i think
ziggy because she's unique is great and
um and dina because she's unique is
great
and i think that's part of the story
that we tell
and he they both solomon and nick are
drawn to that because they don't have it
and uh and they so they want to take it